Speaker 1: All right, I'm coming to you for help
on this. I need people's opinions. About ten days
ago, we received a call when we were taking live
calls from someone who claimed to be a pro-Trump
individual who was formerly a moderator on what's
called The Donald. The Donald was a subreddit
on the website Reddit that was so toxically
pro-Trump and spreading so much disinformation
and so problematic that it was ultimately banned
by Reddit. So this guy calls in and says, Hey,
I used to be a moderator on The Donald and the guy
spread even on this program, disinformation about
ivermectin and misoprostol and okay, we already
talked about that. I didn't think much more about
it. But in the time that followed the release of
that clip, I started getting messages from people
saying, Hey, David, we think that that guy who
called is Ron Watkins and wrote in and and said,
Hi, David, love your show. Thank you for
the quality work you do. I just had to
share that the recent caller who said he was a
moderator for The Donald or whatever it's called
to me, his voice sounds like Ron Watkins. Just
wondering. And then another viewer wrote in,
Evan, who said, The Donald equals Ron Watkins.
Hey, David, love the show is my sister says
after I shared a few videos. He is so astute
and cute too. Okay, I just listened to the new
upload regarding Tricked by a Trumpist.
The caller sounds just like Ron Watkins,
the alleged for Channel QAnon leader, and also
the guy running for Arizona's Congressional
second District. Could this be the same guy? And
I have to tell you, I went back and listened to it
and there's definitely a similarity. Let's
listen to the Voice. This is Ron Watkins
during a recent debate. This is the Cunanan guy
running in Arizona. He made that really strange
opening statement. Listen to his voice here.
Speaker 2: And I will make sure that your
rights are are kept. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Okay. Here's one more
clip. Ron Watkins, listen to The Voice.
Speaker 5: Ron, some people say that
a lot of this was stopped by. Q Anon,
what is your relationship with Cunanan?
Speaker 2: I have no relationship
with Cunanan. None at all. Not at all.
Speaker 5: The reports are that your bulletin
board sites hosted postings that launched and
launched a Q and on conspiracy.
Speaker 2: So I run a free speech
website and I was an administrator and there were
many thousands of thousands of people that posted
on those sites. Q Was just one of those and
I do not know who it was and I'm not there.
Speaker 1: Okay. So that that's the voice of Ron
Watkins. Now, let's listen to the voice of the
guy who called me. All right. Tell me if you
think this is the same person. Let's go next
to let's go to Rich from Illinois. Rich, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Hello. So I was clubmate of
the Donald on Reddit for years until just before
it was banned. And with Elan buying Twitter,
do you think that there will be a general shift in
policy for the tech places towards allowing things
like medical misinformation?
Speaker 1: There's definitely a
similarity. The guy said his name is rich
rather than run. Okay. I guess you could
give a different name. What do you think? Is it
possible that this is the same guy? It's a very
interesting question and multiple people
wondering. Let's listen to a little bit more.
Speaker 2: Such as Ivermectin and what Vice's
motherboard did yesterday with tweeting out
the misoprostol for abortion pills.
Speaker 1: I don't know, guys, that it's it
is very, very interesting. There is absolutely
some kind of similarity. But first of all,
in the middle of a congressional campaign, I don't
know why Ron Watkins would be calling this show.
Secondly, I don't know why he would use the name
Rich. I don't know. I mean, maybe maybe he would
maybe there's a good reason why he would. Maybe
it's logical that he would because he's running
a congressional campaign. But it is very
interesting. And that call generating so
much content. And now people are saying it sounds
like the Q guy. So let me know what you think.
I don't have any other particular information
about it, but it is certainly very interesting.